everyone knows that one man's trash is
another man's treasure and even the
worst moments in film history can serve
a purpose so maybe that's why these
deleted scenes are so fascinating
because they bear such a hilarious and
terrifying reminder of how easily one
scene could destroy a whole movie the
Star Wars prequels are pretty much the
definition of a mixed bag on the one
hand the visuals are often stunning they
have no shortage of bold ideas and the
lightsaber duels are nothing short of
spectacular on the other hand but
there's truly baffling deleted scene
from Revenge of the Sith is a terrifying
reminder that as bad as the prequels
could be at times that could have been
so much worse the scene takes place
after Anakin and obi-wan board general
Grievous's ship to rescue the kidnapped
Chancellor Palpatine the two Jedi are
unsure of which way to go so they
contact everyone's favorite droid r2d2
for directions but they're stumped
because their communicator can't
translate his beeps and bops into actual
words and then this happens I'm pretty
sure that beep is down
I sense Count Dooku is above us oh yes
yes yes you're right beep is up it goes
without saying that this is the only
time we've ever seen a human do that in
Star Wars the moment is played for
laughs and it's kind of weirdly charming
but it also makes absolutely zero sense
and completely breaks the reality of the
film even though it's probably a good
thing that this clip was unearthed and
put on the Internet
so that everyone can marvel at how
gloriously dumb it is it's probably also
a good thing that it didn't actually
make it into Star Wars Canon Back to the
Future has gone down in history as a
classic movie for a good reason not only
does it succeed at being a thrilling
sci-fi adventure story and a hilarious
comedy at the same time but it also has
a genuinely good heart and not many
movies can say all that but there are
certain elements of the film that
haven't aged well and undermine how
sweet the rest of it is in particular
Back to the Future isn't great in terms
of its portrayal of gender and sexuality
it's one thing for Biff to be a predator
that's obviously terrible but he's at
least clearly a villain it's quite
another thing however that the
theoretically adorable young George
McFly's horrifying hobby of spying on
undressing women is played for laughs
and if that wasn't enough the film had
an additional cringe-worthy deleted
scene that might have ruined the care
of Doc Brown and Marty McFly if the
filmmakers had lucked it in in this
scene as Doc Brown attempts to get Marty
ready for his fake date with his mother
doc makes a less than stellar comment
which really does deserve to be left in
the past well I just don't know if I can
go through with it
hitting honor don't please said anything
about hitting her it just could take a
few liberties with her then after that
Marty worries out loud how putting moves
on his mom might turn him gay just be
glad we ended up in the timeline where
this horrible scene was erased from
existence in the hobbits an unexpected
journey Bilbo and his dwarfish
companions encounter a series of
difficult trials on their journey to
slay the Dragons mouth one of the most
difficult spots in which these heroes
find themselves comes when they're
captured by goblins in the mountains as
diarist things seem for them in the
finished movie there was a deleted scene
in which the king of the goblins forces
the dwarves to endure a form of torture
that was deemed too cruel and unusual to
depict on the screen a goblin musical
number the song is called down in goblin
town man there's no way to sugarcoat
this it's terrible you could argue that
it's supposed to be bad it's one of my
own compositions based on an
intentionally atonal song from the
original book and does a good job of
characterizing the goblins as weird
little monsters and their king as a
self-important diva who doesn't care for
the well-being of his captive audience
but that doesn't make it okay to be bad
it's also two full minutes long and
nothing actually happens during those
two minutes that's relevant to the plot
in a movie that's already almost three
hours long this scene is almost
insulting Lisa purplish of course as
seems inevitable with any Peter Jackson
Tolkien adaptation the scene was later
reinserted into the film as part of an
extended version given that most of the
cast of the original Ghostbusters were
already established comedians who were
veterans of Saturday Night Live it's no
surprise that a decent portion of the
dialogue was improvised over the course
of filming but director Ivan Reitman
clearly wasn't sure just how absurd the
movies comedy should be among the failed
comedic experiments that he was toying
around with was one particular subplot
that was in retrospect Laureus ly
ill-conceived in the book making
ghostbusters reitman explains that he
had planned to have bill
dan Aykroyd played dual roles not only
is the Ghostbusters Peter Venkman and
race stance but also as a pair of
homeless men named Bo J and cooms
that were supposed to serve as a kind of
mundane counterpoint to the otherwise
world-ending action this year rather
than grounding the movie however right
men immediately knew upon watching
Murray and Aykroyd on film that focusing
on two side characters who were
inexplicably played by the lead actors
would have the completely opposite
effect
however these characters were present in
the novelization of the film
probably because book characters can't
suffer from weird caste Ridley Scott's
1979 film alien is beloved not only as a
work of thought-provoking science
fiction but also a tremendously spooky
horror film along with Jaws alien is
famous for solidifying the conventional
wisdom among horror movie aficionados
that the less of the monster you see the
better there was however a scene deleted
from the middle of alien that violated
the sacred tenant to filmmaking and
proved just how quickly scary can become
silly if a movie shows too much too soon
in the scene while trying to escape the
ship Lambert stumbles upon the alien
sitting on the ground she stares at it
for a moment paralyzed with fear before
the alien kind of just crab walks over
to her it's probably supposed to be
tense but from the way the scene is
framed and pasted it ends up being
totally ridiculous and not even remotely
scary as cool as the effects were in
alien
this scene is a reminder that terrifying
creatures look way better in quick
glimpses allowing your mind to fill in
the details when you have the chance to
see the aliens entire body for a long
period of time in a well-lit room it
quickly becomes very clear you're just
looking at a guy in a rubber suit the
setting of Who Framed Roger Rabbit seems
absurd at first glance because it is a
film noir version of Los Angeles in
which real people live alongside
cartoons as separate social classes
despite this strange premise the
world-building ends up being remarkably
consistent and it's pretty easy to get
your head around it once the story gets
going but that might not have been the
case if one sanity shattering scene had
made it through the final edit after
being captured by the villains
protagonist Eddie Valentine's that his
head has been trapped inside a cartoon
pig head that seems to be at least
partially alive
Oh
[Music]
after freaking out for a moment
Eddie escapes from his cartoon
confinement in an equally cartoon light
way relative to all the other weird gags
in this movie this one is much harder to
understand largely because it doesn't
seem to be based on anything from
pre-existing cartoon convention was the
pig head once a part of a larger
organism that was beheaded or did the
bad guy somehow creates a sentient
severed pig head from nothing did Eddie
kill the creature when he washed it down
the drain there's no way to answer these
questions without getting into some
really existential territory
perhaps the wildest thing about this
scene is that even with hindsight
director Robert Zemeckis doesn't seem to
think that it was all that weird the
only reason he cut it was because it
slowed down the movie released during
the same summer as iron man and [ __ ] is
something of a forgotten oddity from a
time before the MCU had redefined
superhero movies it stars Will Smith and
Charlize Theron and has the script
co-written by Vince Gilligan who later
went on to create Breaking Bad
although the film only got mixed reviews
when it came out no one could fault it
for lacking ambition it was a bold
deconstruction of superhero conventions
with no costumes code names or
explosions aiming to be more of a comedy
drama than a non-stop action movie
nevertheless one deleted scene did
feature an explosion of sorts during the
scene the depressed alcoholic superhero
Hancock is having a casual fling with a
woman he doesn't really know fooling
around with her on the couch in his
mobile home before things go further
however he tries to warn her about some
of the side effects that may occur
during their impending countr started to
climb in the mountaintop you know
unfortunately she's far too eager to
heed his warnings so she's thrown across
the room while Hancock recovers
considering the scene is nothing more
than a long setup to a silly joke it
probably deserved to be left on the
cutting room floor although the
Terminator films are generally pretty
grim they're not afraid of getting a
little goofy every once a while but one
scene deleted from Terminator 3 rise of
the machines might have taken things a
little too far the scene depicts a
promotional video for cyber research
systems the company that developed the
original terminators in case you don't
remember terminators are killer robot
from the future many of whom are
designed to look and sound like Arnold
Schwarzenegger and this video introduces
its audience to the human whose likeness
was used as the base for these robots
Chief Master Sergeant William candy
who's voiced by samuel l.jackson it is
now within our power to make war see the
real icing on the cake however is when
one of the politicians watching the
video complains about Candy's accent I
don't know about that accent we can fix
it
the whole affair is completely
unnecessary thoroughly Domon up early
delightful even though it was cut many
Terminator fans have accepted this
wonderfully weird scene as Cannon and
William candy has his own entry on the
terminator wiki James Cameron's 1997
blockbuster hit film Titanic is no
stranger to the concept of dramatic
irony so this is the ship they say is on
the single it is unsinkable God Himself
cannot see this concept works pretty
well for Titanic however considering
it's clear from the beginning how things
are going to end in case you forgot your
high school it's dramatic irony is a
literary device in which the audience
has more knowledge of the events of a
story than the characters do which lends
these characters words an additional
layer of meaning they themselves don't
understand when writing a historical
fiction epic like Titanic the temptation
to write nothing but jokey lines that
wink at the audience must be
overwhelming generally however Cameron
does a good job of limiting his use of
dramatic irony save for one particular
instance hey Sonny how about a little
ice
[Music]
needless to say Cameron eventually
decided that this the most dramatic
moment of the film was not the right
time for a really terrible dad joke
probably a solid decision check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]